do you watch minions dude i [ __ ] i do
i like don't even want to talk about it
why because
i the marketing sorry about that i just
i know
they must have spent probably a billion
dollars on marketing for that [ __ ]
movie oh yeah that's oil money 600
million plus publicity
you know click on that link right there
yeah
minions rides into theaters on 600
million dollars
plus publicity spree 600 million 600
million dollars in hype
600 mil and this was for the last one
or this is for this one
yeah
so imagine
like all the places you're seeing the
newest one yeah true yeah
i still think the suit thing
was organic yeah i know it it is really
funny that that's
cool
like until like you know when agencies
try to do things yeah but like the cole
bennett video and that song like that's
all [ __ ] studio [ __ ] that did that it
is
but i think
the i think the yeet thing was
unintentional because apparently you
know cole they paid coal to do that
trail yeah but i think cole was like i'm
using yeet
and i think he kind of forced their hand
so i don't think they realized what
bringing yeet into it would do
i think they did is what i'm saying but
i'm just saying don't be surprised if
you next year you see
like on that website ad world or
whatever yeah some deck from some
marketing agency where like yeah we came
up with general minions
and yeah the proof
yeah
maybe yeah
you're right though it's it's totally
possible
so anyways did you watch the movie no i
didn't
did you oh yeah i did no way you did
yeah you went to the theater and watched
yeah i got the amc pass man i'm in there
what does that mean
[Music]
uh
you wouldn't know because you don't like
movie theaters is that one of those
things where you like pay monthly and
you can yeah unlimited movies yeah yeah
that's pretty sick it's worth
super worth first of all well
first i watched black foam
and then i watched minions within a few
days of each other that was great saw ot
genesis at the black phone movie that's
cool uh show time what is black phone
it's a horror movie it's another blumkin
house production okay
it's bloomhouse
people say i say bloomhouse wrong so now
i'm saying blumkin bumpkin house was it
good
damn
that's a crazy sound
it
[Music]
it worked okay
it was okay wait black phone or minions
oh minions
what was it good minions was great
god damn it minions was great see we're
getting paid too guys yeah we're getting
paid or are we
you can watch
minions on your amc movie pass
um
no it was good also zayd is in his
minions
dude you are dressed like a minion dude
dude step out here and sit in front of
this guest camera we didn't plan this
guys
so no yeah we did it no we didn't yeah
we did not get paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars for this organic
organic yes organically came out of my
closet and be sure to check out minions
eyes of the group
you know when they full name it then
they're a corporate yeah yeah minions
two semicolon rise of crew
[Laughter]
all right bob i mean uh
zade get back to it yeah i don't know
man so what but was it good it was a
good time was it i had to i have to
admit it
it was a good time damn it
yeah they got like these and that was
minions rise of the crew yeah okay
in theaters now yeah got it got it got
it
yeah
uh no one's gonna know it everyone's
gonna be like did they get paid for that
i am ashamed to admit that i laughed at
all the
just all the minions behavior i was
i have to admit like i enjoyed watching
them be stupid
and uh
yeah there's one scene where
they're running down a hill in san
francisco and one of them trips
and starts rolling on his side
and then the two
of his
friends like running with him like laugh
and they go okay and then they lie on
their sides and roll on purpose i don't
know why that's it just
it just killed me like it's just are you
on shrooms no i i i that would have been
horrifying
they're talking to me
um
there was another aspect to it that
yeah yo that dude otto
you would you would know if you watched
the film but you know you don't [ __ ]
like movies so
it's just it was good you can't give me
[ __ ] oh i can for this oh i can't for
being like that dude that one's so funny
yeah i mean i'm fully a child right now
yeah that's what i'm saying i cannot
justify a grown man oh dude that one
that was my favorite one dude oh that
one's name's otto he's crazy
no he he had some good moments yeah no i
believe it i actually moments i i
actually do think that i like this kind
of movie
[Laughter]
i know you do well i mean i just like
animated movies are like you know you're
never
super gung-ho by watching them and then
you sit down you're like [ __ ] this is
funny yeah i'm not yeah i agree with
that for sure i thought and that makes
me feel better because i thought it was
alone in that no no they make these for
everyone yeah well no the feeling of
sitting down to watch an animated movie
and you're kind of like what am i doing
yeah yeah
maybe that amc pass was not a good idea
yeah i don't know what i'm doing yeah
then you go watch it and you walk out
and like your disney merch with your
disneyland season pass and
[Music]
face
yeah
oh
this one's auto he's my favorite he's my
favorite auto what a quirky guy
now i'm also ashamed to admit that i
laugh super hard at all the super
villains are like stupid one-liners
uh
like the one crab dude his name is john
claude and he's a french dude with like
a
yeah
that's good
and like nunchuck oh okay
it's just so dumb
they're kind of cute
i'm coming around on minions yeah
yeah
coming around dude kind of cute
kind of thick
yeah
they give a lot in this trailer what the
[ __ ]
yeah i feel like we have to say
something to prove that we didn't get
paid for this we definitely didn't i
fully just subscribed but yeah they did
they did wear those damn clothes you got
paid
to come on the show dressed like that
yeah and we didn't get anything it was
part of the 600 million that was part of
the 600 million there's a lot of
branches too yeah why didn't they hit us
up about it why just you
dog it's like a niche
following i have oh okay we gotta
we gotta just pull up his minions next
week i think that's what we have to do
just for free too yeah goggles just
promote the movie for free yeah not get
a taste of that 600 mil yeah